hi everyone and welcome to our session
innovations in ddos waff firewalls and
network-based threat detection
my name is peter bloom and i run the
network security pm team here at google
cloud and i'm joined by emil i'm going
to let introduce himself
thanks peter hi my name is emil keiner
and i run product management for our
ddos mitigation and web application
firewall product line called cloud armor
so today i'm going to start off by
sharing our vision for network security
and provide a brief overview of our
solutions after that i'm going to hand
over to emil who's going to get us up to
date on all the latest with cloud armor
and then i'll pick back up and cover all
the great new things that we've been
doing in network protection with our
cloud firewall nat and ids offerings
so let me start with our broader vision
of network security at google cloud as
you can see in our vision statement our
goal with network security is to make it
invisible
we want to weave it into the cloud
fabric with automated but verifiable
protection
simplified control and clear
prioritization of critical threats with
relevant context and where we can we
also want to provide the solution emil
is actually going to talk about some of
the new capabilities in cloud armor in
just a bit that i think are a perfect
example of what we're working towards
across the entire portfolio
i wanted to provide an overview of our
network security portfolio i'm going to
overlay this on a high level diagram
that's showing flows in between and out
of our cloud
first in terms of handling incoming
traffic to internet facing services we
provide an integrated edge delivery
stack that includes a global load
balancer and cdn that provide for
availability scalability and performance
and then built into this stack to
provide our global scale ddos protection
and a great web application firewall is
cloud armor which emil is going to dig
into shortly
and then we provide defense and depth
with a network firewall and nat service
built into our cloud networking fabric
these same two services also provide for
protection and privacy for traffic out
of the network as well
and as you can expect our network
security solutions are integrated in our
cloud security products bringing in
context about threats
integration with our bot fraud and
application access solutions as well
and then we provide a full complement of
network level telemetry from metadata
about traffic flows inside and out of
the cloud
data about traffic we block at the
network and application layer plus we
provide full packet inspection services
with our packet mirroring capability
and within the next few months you'll
see we've also released network threat
detection it's a system called cloud ids
that leads a joint partnership with palo
alto networks where we use their threat
detection systems within our own cloud
all the alerts and telemetry from these
products are also integrated into our
own threat hunting alert management and
unified security management services and
then we also integrate with third party
sim and soar systems as well
so with that let me hand over to emil to
take us through cloud armor
thanks peter today i'm excited to share
with you all the great new developments
and capabilities we've released with
cloud armor over the past
year cloud armor is google cloud's ddos
protection service and web application
firewall it provides global scale
defense against volumetric protocol and
application level attacks and it's built
using the same technology and
infrastructure that we originally built
to protect our own billion user
properties such as search gmail and maps
cloud armor reflects our vision of
bringing to bear google's global scale
to protect customer workloads wherever
they are deployed
cloud armor in addition to the rest of
our edge infrastructure including load
balancing and cdn
can be deployed in front of your
websites or services whether you are
running on google cloud on-prem or with
another infrastructure provider
over the past year we've been privileged
enough to help protect the growing set
of enterprise customers while moving
quickly to expand our capabilities and
scope of protection all while investing
heavily into building a cutting-edge
machine learning solution to meet the
evolving threat landscape head-on
i'm excited to share with you some of
our recent developments
earlier this year we introduced cloud
armor managed protection plus a managed
application protection service which
bundles together all the features and
capabilities of cloud armor with
additional value-added services into an
enterprise friendly and predictable
monthly subscription
managed protection plus delivers
unrivaled application protection while
providing the peace of mind that google
has your back 24 7.
in addition to including all clad armor
laugh rules policies and requests manage
protection plus includes premium
capabilities like adapter protection as
well as 24 7 ddos response support which
gives you access to google's das experts
to help mitigate attacks targeting your
services
further with ddos bill protection we're
removing the financial risk of ddos by
insulating you from spikes in your
networking expenses caused by successful
ddos attacks
over the next several quarters you'll
see us continue to add additional
premium capabilities and manage services
into manage protection plus subscription
next we want to talk about our new
adaptive protection capability which has
already generated a lot of positive
feedback from a fast growing enterprise
customer base
adapter protection is a machine learning
based solution to detect and efficiently
respond to application level distributed
denial of service attacks
we have developed adaptive protection
over the last several years in close
collaboration with external and internal
customers like project shield
continuously training on attack data we
observe against all of google
adapter protection develops a per
application baseline by learning what
normal traffic patterns look like for
each protected application in addition
to traffic volumes we assess dozens of
features and attributes of the incoming
request traffic to establish the
baseline
next adapter protection monitors traffic
flows in real time and generates alerts
for anomalous or potentially attack
traffic
a second set of machine learning model
then distills the anomalous traffic into
a dynamically generated signature the
result of this analysis is presented
immediately as part of the original
alert
we also take it a step further and
provide a proposed cloud armor rule that
can mitigate the attack traffic with
minimal to no collateral damage to the
good baseline traffic
adaptive protection provides
near-real-time attack detection with
immediately actionable alerts saving
your incident responders critical
minutes or hours of time-consuming log
analysis triage and other ir activities
allowing you to safely and efficiently
deliver reliable services
this is the main adaptive protection
dashboard
here you can see incoming traffic
patterns for all of your services
protected by adaptive protection as well
as the list of attack alerts detected
over the selected time horizon
when we click on one of the alerts
we see a much more detailed view of the
attack and the results of our machine
learning powered analysis
we present the machine determined
confidence level in our findings the
size and shape of the attack as well as
the attack signature
for this attack in particular we have
identified and presented a unique
signature across the source region code
remote host and target host attributes
we also propose a rule that can be
deployed in near real time to mitigate
the attack as it's occurring
because of the sensitivity of our
detection models alerts are frequently
generated while an attack is still
ramping up allowing you to respond
before it has a chance to impact your
services
when the operator clicks apply they can
see the proposed rule as well as
additional guidance from adaptive
protection to aid in understanding and
assessing the expected impact of the
proposed mitigation
mitigations can also be deployed in a
logging only or preview mode to validate
effectiveness and safety
specifically you can see the expected
impact of the proposed rule on the good
and bad traffic in this case the
proposed rule is expected to impact zero
percent of the good traffic from the
baseline
while blocking about all or nearly all
of the incoming attack
so we are providing an end-to-end
solution to detect and mitigate attacks
with near-real-time actionable alerts
containing dynamically generated
mitigations which are narrowly targeted
for just the malicious traffic
this insight not only saves incident
responders critical time in reacting and
mounting an effective defense
but also provides the information to aid
triage efforts and help explain why we
consider the traffic suspicious
next we're proud to announce the preview
release of cloud armor bot management
with a deep integration with recaptcha
enterprise which is google cloud's
enterprise version of the leading bot
and fraud protection product
while customers can use these products
together already we wanted to simplify
the deployment process and provide a
more integrated and scalable experience
recaptcha enterprise provides a
world-class bot detection mechanism
developed from and continuously learning
from a globally distributed
multi-million website install base
with this deep integration cloud armor
customers can now leverage recaptcha to
detect and block bot traffic within
their cloud armor security policies
all of this occurs at the edge of
google's network far upstream of your
protected workloads allowing us to
leverage the global scale of our network
to mitigate bot threats without
impacting the performance of your
applications
critically with the integrated solution
cloud armor and recaptcha enterprise can
protect customer applications without
requiring server-side changes on the
application to decipher and enforce bot
assessments
you can configure cloud armor security
policies in several ways to leverage
this integration
you can configure any rule action to
serve the recapture challenge forcing
suspicious end users to solve the puzzle
before being allowed through
additionally you can instrument your
client-side applications with a
recaptcha library for seamless and
silent bot assessments and then have
cloud armor decipher and enforce the
assessment at the edge
in addition to the recaptcha integration
cloud armor bot management introduces an
enhanced set of capabilities designed to
help you deploy an effective bot
management strategy
these capabilities include additional
rule actions to redirect traffic as well
as the ability to insert a custom header
into a suspicious request but otherwise
allow it to reach your application
customers use this custom header to tag
suspicious traffic for alternative
processing within their workloads like
sending to a honeypot or not completing
a potentially fraudulent transaction
without notifying the bot that it was
detected
we're also proud to share that one of
our most highly anticipated features
rate limiting is now available in
preview
with cloud armor per client rate
limiting users can ensure that no client
exceeds a pre-configured threshold
through two new actions for any existing
or new cloud armor rule
with the throttle action requests from
individual clients will be dropped when
the client begins exceeding the
prescribed rate to ensure that on
average the client's request volume
stays within the configured threshold
similarly the rate-based ban action aims
to punish abusive clients by temporarily
banning them
for a configured amount of time if they
exceed your threshold
and clients can be identified by their
source ip exported for header or any
arbitrary header like a session
identifier or a user id
cloud armor rate limiting is an
effective means to detect and thwart
high volume ddos attempts mitigate
credential stuffing attacks all while
ensuring the availability and
reliability of your workloads
finally cloud armor edge security
policies are available in preview to
provide cloud armor protection in front
of cloud cdn cache or google cloud
storage buckets
the new edge security policy types can
be applied to protected services in
parallel with the existing back-end
security policies
the new policy types are stored
evaluated and enforced even further
upstream in our edge infrastructure
before a request can be served from the
cdn's cache or from a gcs bucket
requests that make it through the edge
security policy that cannot be served
from cache are still evaluated by any
configured back-end security policy
for full layer 7 filtering and waff
before it is proxied back to your
protected application or origins
edge security policies support ip and
geo filtering to filter out unwelcome
end users or geographies in order to
comply with security compliance
export controls or licensing agreements
while delivering these much anticipated
capabilities we are continuing to invest
heavily into expanding cloud armor scope
and depth of protection to help protect
your applications and services so stay
tuned
now i'll hand it back to peter to tell
you about more great developments across
our network security products
thanks emil it's uh great to hear about
all the good stuff that's happening with
clod armor
next i'd like to get into what's new and
innovative with network protection i'm
going to cover innovations in cloud
firewall cloudnat and cloud ids
so let's start with cloud firewall this
is our integrated virtual firewall
service for ingress egress and inside
the cloud network protection it's fully
integrated with google's sdn fabric and
the firewall policy enforcement is
distributed across that fabric
and to make firewall policies dynamic we
allow for easier micro segmentation and
provide a shift to a zero trust workload
protection posture by using network tags
and service accounts
this removes the need for encoding
static ip addresses into firewall rules
and makes protection dynamic you know
the example i like to give is you can
add new micro services with a tag and
they'll automatically get the
established protection rules
and in terms of recent innovations we
have two great additions
first is firewall insights which
provides information that helps
operators learn about which firewall
rules are used never used and
overshadowed by other more broad rules
this helps identify misconfigurations
attacks and allows tightening controls
for better security
and then we just released a new
capability and preview here that
highlights rules that have perhaps over
granted permissions which is a great
opportunity to tighten up your firewall
rules
next we released hierarchical firewall
policies earlier this year which allows
creating and enforcing a consistent set
of firewall policies across an entire
organization
this improves protection and simplifies
complex large deployments the great
thing is that once you set up your
organization's standard set of firewall
policies any new projects added
automatically get that policy
but it still allows for local overrides
deeper within the organization when
required
we find it's really helping customers
simplify their firewall configurations
by reducing the number of firewall rules
needed across an organization
next up is cloudnat this is our
integrated network address translation
service
like our firewall it's built into the
fabric and provides security and privacy
for outbound connections with the
ability to use static or auto allocated
ips
and like our firewall it's built into
the network fabric versus a single
gateway so you can scale it up to
thousands of vms
and in terms of recent innovations we
have two great additions in preview now
at the show
the first is nat rules which allow for
tighter control over which external ips
are used for different internal
requesters for example you can ensure a
service making requests out over nat
always uses the same public ip address
and then we introduced a new capability
in preview called dynamic port
allocation this allows for higher scale
by automatically optimizing nat port
utilization in real time
previously customers had to manually
configure port allocations across vms
and they were generally over allocating
now the system does it for you on its
own automatically
and we just recently announced our new
cloud ids product which provides for
managed network threat detection with
high levels of security efficacy and low
noise
it's quick and easy to deploy it's
managed scaled and operated by google
with high performance and availability
all built in
it's super easy to set up with a few
clicks you just select what you want to
monitor which types of monitoring you
want to enable and then the
logging and telemetry is all integrated
into all our own systems like cloud
logging
chronicle and all the alerts flow to scc
we can also send the alerts and
telemetry to third-party sim and sort
products as well
and then we're super excited to share
that we partnered with our friends at
palo alto networks to embed their
industry-leading threat detection
technologies in the product
so this ensures we have industry-leading
detection capabilities both in terms of
breadth of coverage and efficacy
and it's all backed by their expert
production proven technologies and
world-class threat intelligence teams
but all nicely integrated into google
cloud sold and supported by us
in fact i wanted you to hear from our gm
of iis sachin gupta and palo alto
networks svp anand oswal more about the
collaboration that led to this product
[Music]
the introduction of google cloud ideas
that's right anand it's been an
incredible partnership and we're now
taking it to a completely new level
over the last year our engineering teams
have worked together to build a new
joint product that combines the
industry-leading capabilities of palo
alto networks in advanced network threat
detection with the simplicity and scale
of google cloud
we're calling this product cloud ids a
cloud native service delivered to all
our customers
with just a few clicks customers can
inspect traffic get application level
visibility and detect advanced threats
they don't need to worry about
throughput they don't need to worry
about
redirecting network traffic to the
service it's all done in a cloud-native
way as part of the normal workflow
they don't need to worry about scale
this is a service that's always on that
is highly performant and that scales on
demand
this is google cloud simplicity at its
finest and it's something that customers
should consider deploying in every
single vpc anand why don't you talk more
about the strength of the security
capabilities that palo alto networks
brings as part of cloud ids absolutely
sachin the core of what we do in the
cloud ids product is a network detection
engine
this is a machine learning powered
engine it looks at over 15 trillion
transactions every single day with all
our network security products and our
endpoints we're constantly looking at
millions and millions of samples of
malware
these are processed to ensure that we
protect our customers from day zero
threats
we're pushing over 4.3 million unique
security updates every single day
and that's not enough in addition to our
automated analysis we have 200 of our
finest threat researchers of our unit 42
organization that do in-depth research
and have the best understanding of the
entire threat landscape
but such in the point you talked about
combining simplicity ensuring that
you're having security we're bringing
these two together with this joint
product if you'd like to learn more
about cloud ids go to cloud.google.com
ids
[Music]
we love the collaboration with palo alto
networks which has led to a super easy
to deploy network threat detection
system but with production proven high
efficacy all powered by palo alto
networks
well thanks so much for joining us today
and thank you emil for co-presenting
with me we were glad you were able to
join us to learn more about innovations
in ddos firewalls and network threat
detection you can visit us on the web at
cloud.google.com
products slash networking and then the
cloud networking team has a great set of
sessions during next where you can learn
more about how we're simplifying
networking
delivering new services and all about
what we're doing on the edge thanks
again
you